toast happy st. Patrick's Day happy st.
Patty's Day to our lovers may they
withstand our abuse this evening livers
our livers not sorry I've never abused a
lover I would like to make a st.
Patrick's Day toast to Conan O'Brien and
all of the nice people here at this
wonderful show Cheers
my grandfather came to this country from
County Armagh in 1928 makes me so happy
to see people celebrating my native land
happy st. Patrick's Day happy st.
Paddy's Day happy st. Patrick's Day
Coenen happy st. Paddy's Day Coenen
happy st. Patty's Day buddy is that
that's really bad no did I get a bad one
or something what did you give me that
is not green beer that is disgusting why
would you do that what is this no this
is not green beer that's blood that's
blood you guys can all go yourself ok
well that's harsh write me an apology
note or something because I'll tell you
one thing I'm never coming back here
take this someone needs to take this
right now don't look sorry you don't
seem sorry you don't ask someone to do a
bit and take part in something and give
them stuff that tastes like Jesus Christ
it's what it's just regular beer is it
regular beer cause it tastes like I'm
sick you see this you know it's I'm
sorry you don't seem as sorry as you
should be for what I just put in my
mouth I'll go again I'll go again
no I'm not gonna fake [ __ ] but I don't
fake sip green beer it's st. Patty's Day
sir and happy st. Patty's I can't even
smell it I don't give it because what
you got is what you got so you can cut
around it and make it work or throw in
the garbage
we'll roll on the door cuz I'm done
[Music]